there is john gray former number one
pick of the rockies making his 17th
start he had a short stint on the
injured list earlier this year and one
of three rocky starter
one-two pitch swang and a miss
good sink
even though it looked more like a four
seamer he had good down action to get
the opening strikeout this is another
relatively easy ground ball
that's a seven-pin start for john gray
he has very competitive numbers and
that's in the right field of base hit
and spillia
that would be left to charlie blackman
this ball lied to left center charlie
blackman comes through hanson to cruise
home
as the rockies take a one-nothing lead
clutch two out first knock from chuck
nasty
blackman takes off
throw the second
rock we haven't seen charlie run
literally a couple of years that was his
first stolen base attempt of the year
that was the old first move go
you know because david price
didn't even really pay attention to it
lake comes up charlie takes off
he's in there quite easily for his first
stolen bases stolen base number 54 for
the
[Applause]
run for rockies
and it's 2-1 dodgers
justin turner with an opposite field
smash
his 16th of the year
smith hits it hard through the hole in
the left side that's a base hit
right
swung on it so gray comes back and
strikes out mckinstry two-run home run
of the inning from justin turner
and now in the third the dodgers lead
two to one
john great talent off in the rockies
dugout he just struck out zach mckinstry
on uh
slider down and in and for john that was
his 774th career strikeout we make
mention of that because it now places
him in second place all time
on the rockies career strikeout list
behind jorge de la rosa
good pass to baldo
reed side arms it and ceo laces it into
center field for a base hit
[Applause]
this is popped up easy play on the right
side
little miscommunication between taylor
and foxy for a moment
and then the ball was dropped by chris
taylor and it's 2-2
[Applause]
[Music]
really fun to watch john pitch today
he is to the outside corner and this is
a towering pop-up mcmahon foul groud
he's got room he's got the baseball
and john
has now retired
12 in a row
[Applause]
two two
[Applause]
mcmahon yeah he stayed back nice on that
curveball from kelly
ground ball turner off his glove mcmahon
scores always will head to third
matt arms comes through
and the rockies lead it three to two
turn down to third that's mcmahon and
into the corner
around first and on his way to second
with a one-out double is justin turner
16th double of the season for jt
and the tying run
in scoring position
smith goes down and golf's one deep to
left it is gone a home run for will
smith
oh where there's a will there's a way
and the dodgers have taken the lead in
the eighth
two singles in a strikeout against the
starter john gray and he'll hit a ball
to left coming on owings on the dive
makes the catch
chris coming in at the last moment
realized he was gonna
have to leave his feet made a dive
forward and snagged it
short
trevor's got a lot of time to throw but
it's gloved by crown
one two three inning for bar now the
rockies have to put a rally together
against kenley janssen
and this ball is lifted to right center
field and d back
off the base of the wall
mcmahon will stop at second that's a
great start to the night
there's his first career hit against
jackson and it came at a great time too
here we go chris owens infield in
and a live
owens comes through
mcmahon scores and the rockies are
tighter
and he lines one into right center field
for a base hit pujols rounding
here comes the throw it's offline albert
scores and will smith
does it one more time today to give the
dodgers the lead
this is plenty deep enough in right
field hanson tags
and he scores to tie it up so trevor
story comes through on a 3-2 pitch
he gets the
[Music]
got the job done with the productive out
charlie an rbi single back in the first
he's one for four he's the 1-1 for
bickford
[Applause]
that's his first big fly since june the
third against the texas rangers
[Applause]
the 10th racket
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he's been the recipient of that kind of
celebration
[Applause]